I'm a professor of medicine and
professor of medical sociology at
Harvard Medical School and a professor
of sociology at in the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences and I do what I would call
network science so I for the last 10
years have been studying how and why
human beings come to be embedded in
social networks not the kind of online
kind that people might think about all
the time nowadays but the kind of very
ancient kind that we have formed for
hundreds of thousands of years and I
study how we humans come to form these
very elaborate networks and what these
networks come to mean for our lives and
the sort of the field as it were of of
the medical sociology is concerned with
all sorts of phenomena social processes
and social phenomena that influence
health and healthcare so but I'm focused
primarily on a I would say a subset of
that or not a subset but a different
field let's say Network science
work on the social psychological
mathematical and biological roles that
govern how human beings come to form
social networks the structure of
networks and then we've also examined
the kind of social and psychological
rules or attributes of how social
networks function so how do we form
social networks and how do they affect
our lives and it's what we would
consider to be the anatomy and the
physiology of a kind of human super
organism in a very fundamental way we
are we're like ants or actually kind of
like fungi to where individual human
beings assemble themselves into these
elaborate complex structures and we're
James Fowler and I my co-author are
deeply concerned with how and why we
form these structures and what they mean
for our lives so in the book we we
present about we we talked a lot about
our own research but we also pull in the
research of many other scientists who've
been looking at a variety of phenomena
and we we talk about the role of social
networks in in human emotions we talk
about the role of social networks in in
human romantic and sexual behavior in in
health in politics and in economics and
then we also talk a little bit about the
genetics of human social networks and
the sort of modern online variety of
social interactions and then we close
with an argument in the book about why
why we form social networks and what in
a very deep sense they mean for our
lives